it's the moment that the villages in San
cidro Gano have been waiting
for they one of the many isolated
communities around the Mexican coastal
town of aapo who'd yet to receive Aid
after Hurricane Otis hit the area last
Wednesday now the Navies finally arrived
they told us what they've been going
through there are sick children vomiting
because we're having to drink water from
the
Stream this is it a dirty stream and a
cloudy well the only sources of water
after the hurricane sealed them in trees
and Deb blocking the roads
here they say a lot of children have
become sick in the last week maybe
because of
that she has maky eyes and marks all
over her body and there's been no
medicine here either or Food Supplies on
top of that many people have lost their
homes made of a derby with corrugated
iron roofs the hurricane made short work
of
them everything has been destroyed the
majority of the families are looking for
refuge in the school the church the
village hall because there is nowhere to
shelter now the Navy's airlifting in
supplies not just here but in other
communities across the area running 15
to 25 flights a day in their hastily
organized Depot they tell us it's often
hard to get Aid to its destination right
now looting and lawlessness has gripped
aapo people are in need to stop vehicles
and force them to give up the products
that's why we're also providing security
and for vehicles traveling with
Aid at least by air it's sure to arrive
the community here are really glad to
see this food and water arrive they say
they've been cut off for about a week
but they also say that it's not going to
be enough they're going to need a lot
more the Navy estimates they'll be
running these missions for a month
longer donations are coming in to help
full recovery will take so much longer
for these communities but at least it's
a start John Homan ala sanid
Gano make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer